I know exactly what we can do while we
wait
Riverdale star Vanessa Morgan speaking
out about black representation on
television including her own show she
posted this message to Twitter quote
tired of how black people are portrayed
in media tired of us being portrayed as
thugs dangerous or angry scary people
tired of us also being used as sidekick
non-dimensional characters to our white
leads or only used in the ads for
diversity but not actually in the show
it starts with the media she also said
she's not being quiet anymore I find I
know you know a little bit of every
other characters background I really
don't know mine or sweet peas or fangs
so between our little gang I would love
to know more about like what happened to
my parents Drive siblings how are you
feeling Mila Vanessa also said she will
not take roles that don't properly
represent us I mean that's what I've
been waiting for I'm trying I have my
story like made up in my head you know
so I'm just like waiting to see it on
the paper if that's you know reality of
what I think Tony's life is you know the
actress who plays Tony topes on the show
got a ton of support on Twitter but
asked fans not to attack or her co-stars
quote my role on Riverdale has nothing
to do with my fellow castmates slash
friends they don't write the show so no
need to attack them they don't call the
shots and I know they have my back
co-star Lili Reinhardt was quick to show
support to vanessa tweeting quote we
love you v and support you 10,000%
co-star Haley la also tweeted quote I've
felt this from the beginning we are so
much more my mind my parents are in jail
that's just kind of like how I
envisioned it removing my dad's in jail
and my mom kind of disappeared out of
the picture you know maybe you know
drugs et reached out to Warner Brothers
they declined to comment besides seeing
her back story of the family I would
love to see her still being the strong
confident independent girl that she was
when you met her in season 2 you know
she didn't take the s from anybody